dominate the opponent's knight now  anishkiri does have  real real chances of being able to give  up the black knight  for white's two remaining pawns if he  does that it's a draw a bishop on its  own cannot deliver checkmate  so black's knight now going after the  white pawns rajabov  has he missed this move he's missed a  golden opportunity what does he have  planned  he's just allowing all of his pawns to  be taken the white pawns are  disappearing  okay so knight takes pawn what else  and now there is a big threat the knight  is going to maneuver itself  to threaten the last remaining white  pawn  and he's just allowed it yeah rajabov  has allowed the draw he has missed an  open goal in this game  look at geary's face he is so relieved  he knew  he was dead lost in that end game  rajabov with a bishop extra bishop but  not enough to win wow  what an ending to this game it  really looked like timora java was  winning  the second game against anishka